ma buon 2016 barba incolta capelli
spettinati vogliono dire soltanto una
cosa pausa è tornato e questa volta con
una chicca che adoravo quando ero
bambino i bio combat e porto subito con
una domanda perché voglio sinceramente
saperlo in quanti sapevate quando
eravate piccoli che i bio combat fosse
una serie di transformers
io non lo sapevo per esempio nonostante
gli indizi fossero abbastanza palesi ma
nessuno me lo aveva mai detto
direttamente
sarà stato anche per il titolo che da
noi è arrivato con il nome di bio combat
e per essere più precisi rombi di tuono
e cieli di fuoco per i bio kombat
questo è uno di quei nomi che non ti
dimentichi facilmente ma la serie
originale si chiamava transformers visto
wars ecco tipo questo sarebbe stato un
buon inizio per farmi capire che
transformers visto wars fosse una serie
dei e transformers vadano è arrivata
così e cena teniamo così ma questo
titolo mi ha ricordato quanto cazzo
fosse [ __ ] la sigla questa è una di
quelle canzoni che mi porto dall
adolescenza e che ogni tanto canto a
caso a casa ma basta divagare guardiamo
insieme il primo episodio di rombi di
tuono e cieli di fuoco per i bio kombat
l'episodio inizia nello spazio
l'atterraggio sei sicura che pista wars
si traduca in atterraggio è ma eravamo
dei mocciosi chi cacchio lo sapeva
l'inglese dove due astronavi galattiche
stanno avendo una spaventosa battaglia
rispetta i sistemi di controllo o no ho
perso pure tutte le mie polaroid
mi piace come i colpi della nave
avversaria abbiano fatto dei buchi
sull'astronave a forma di esplosione
piazza c'è un adesivo della acme e siamo
a posto prima di precipitare decidono di
cagare fuori dall'astronave tutte le
scialuppe di salvataggio
e mentre altre cartoline vengono fatte
volare fuori dall'astronave avversaria
entrambe precipitano sul pianeta
riusciranno a sopravvivere in un
territorio come questo
chissà che vi siete dimenticati di
renderizzare parte dello scenario sto
giocando con l'accesso anticipato di
steam l'astronave dave maximal se cade
in una zona desertica abbiamo subito ma
che razza di na man mai ragione scusa
scuse accettate il caro il mio maxima
alza cui hanno scritto dialoghi del
cazzo
mentre l'astronave dei preda con sé
caduta nella zona vulcanica ma gli è
andata di culo perché il pianeta è pieno
zeppo di energon affermativo che il
materiale necessario per la conquista
dell'universo a mi piace l'idea che per
conquistare l'universo servano degli
ingredienti come se fosse una ricetta
della clerici praticamente ma ce ne è
talmente tanto di energon nel pianeta
che loro non possono rimanere nella loro
forma robotica rimanere
forma robotica apporterà danni
irreparabili e quindi sono costretti a
trasformarsi e ovviamente anche i maxi
mans fanno la stessa cosa
porca [ __ ] la faccia che fa il ghepardo
o non di nuovo è il primo robot che
vediamo si è trasformato proprio nel di
pardo
guardatemi sono un ghepardo sì certo
sono io che ban o svariate domande da
fare
1 avete appena detto di esservi
schiantati in un pianeta sconosciuto
come fai a sapere che quella animale si
chiama proprio che bardot 2 perché hai
dovuto cambiare nome chiamarti ghepard
scusami se tu prima della trasformazione
ti chiamavi franco e tutti i tuoi amici
ti chiamano franco perché ti sei
chiamato ghepard ti sei comunque franco
trasformato in un ghepardo numero 3
se uno scanner non avesse captato degli
animali ma tipo fossi sceso a new york e
avessi captato tipo un sexy shop come si
sarebbe evoluta la faccenda qui ma certo
si fantastica allora innanzitutto stai
calmo il secondo robot si trasforma in
un topo
chiedo scusa cos'è che aveva detto
megatron e allora creeremo norme
alternative
ispirandoci alle più potenti creature
locali a sé missione compiuta
tra l'altro è veramente incredibile che
i loro nuovi nomi coincidano
perfettamente con l'animale con cui si
siano trasformati il mio nome harry noms
magia e dulcis in fundo lui quello che
dovrebbe essere optimus prime
ma che qui è chiamato black dove sono i
tuoi genitali o blackjack mi dispiace
odio dover tela dire di persona questa
cosa qui ma mi sa che il radar ha
causato il negozio della trudi parlo a
nome di tutti i fan di bio combat questa
settimana in ricordo dei [ __ ] di
blackjack
mettiamo nel l'avatar di facebook
1 scroto di un gorilla lo faccio per te
break
tralasciando le stronzate io non ho
capito una cosa com'è possibile che un
gorilla un topo un rinoceronte un
ghepardo siano stati captati tutti nella
stessa zona desertica tra l'altro vabbè
che il pianeta potrebbe essere alieno
però so se ho sbagliato per a vamo
all'inseguimento di megatron quindi
potremmo essere in qualunque luogo e
tempo e qualunque lago anche questo tra
l'altro era uno dei pochi cartoni
animati in cui io tifavo per i nemici
perché perché alcuni di loro si sono
trasformati in dei cazzo di dinosauri e
non solo dinosauri robo dinosauri guarda
quanto è figo megatron è come se barney
fosse stato addestrato da the rock 60 un
capo e incompetente ma cosa gli vuoi
dire ad un nemico così avrei una cosa da
dirgli come hai fatto a trasformarti in
un dinosauro intero se quello che eri
scannerizzato erano solo fossili sarebbe
quello che avrebbe chiesto il
ventisettenne se avessi visto questo
cartone animato per la prima volta ma
siccome ero un bambino non me ne fregava
niente trasformazione
dove cazzo gli devo mettere prendi ne
danno i giochi quello edinho botte e
litiga con megatron perché non gli sta
tanto a genio che sia lui il capo
vorrebbe essere se stesso bla bla bla
nel frattempo shepard vede sul pianeta
altre forme di vita simili a lui e cerca
di fare amicizia non fa bene alla morti
theo mettete due alberi due ciuffi
d'erba ma spero che siate pronti per la
reaction più sopra le righe che abbiate
mai visto in 3 2 1 mi chiamo che è per
niente paura sì ma queste non sono le
facce di uno che ha visto un ghepardo
parlare questa è la reazione per aver
visto qualcosa di molto molto peggio
solo un comico quando all'improvviso
arriva un altro preda cons
è un ape barra vespa quindi io dico che
si chiama vespa tricks o pungi nator chi
cazzo li ha dati nomina bambina di 8
anni ma con la sua super interfaccia da
robot che si sono dimenticati di mettere
a fuoco contro pare attacca ghepard gap
a massimi ca
no no
ogni volta che vedo un gap ha
trasformato non ci vedo un robot da
combattimento ma la zitella di 55 anni
che s'è vestita per andare a rimorchiare
la sera senza offesa tutte le zitelle
che ci seguono pieno così e dopo aver
passato mezz'ora a fare pio pio l'un con
l'altro blackjack se ne accorge
sto guardando un gorilla a cavallo di un
rinoceronte con in mano un topo e sto
bevendo solo acqua raggiungono ghepard
per salvarlo ma in quel momento arrivano
anche altri preda cons e finalmente ci
sono tutti gli estremi per una battaglia
è tra l'altro prima non scherzavo dire
pio pio x che fanno veramente pio pio le
battaglie massimizza
ma che cavolo di trasformazione ciao
blackjack
perché mai dovrebbe girare il suo intero
busto al contrario per trasformarsi e
quindi blackjack
non solo 6 asessuato ma c'è pure il culo
davanti e provo profonda pietà per il
salvatore dell'universo durante la
battaglia viene sparato un missile a
ghepard che per cercare di schivarlo e
va incontro attivo ma non puoi riuscire
a salvare l'universo se poi una roccia
ti blocca per sempre fortunatamente
aveva blackjack e lo salva torniamo alla
base vabbè la prospettiva non è
importante nei piani italiani dai e
adesso c'è una scena che mi dovete
aiutare a capire se sono solo io stronzo
che ho pensato una cosa cerca di essere
più ottimista forse viviamo in un
periodo storico malizioso ma se io
questa scena la guardo con questa musica
ma del top ma sulla strada incontrano di
nobotalk colle che vuole diventare il
loro capo ha finalmente lasciato in
prede con vero nir mia massima dino bot
dati pace nessuno ti vuole come amico
nessuno ti vuole tanto meno come capo la
puntata in teoria finisce così questa
sarebbe solo la prima parte del prologo
ma noi basta la prima puntata è quindi
grazie questo era rombi di tuono e cieli
di fuoco per i bio kombat
lo so che invecchiato male e so anche
che questi tipi di personaggi sono fatti
apposta per vendere giocattoli ma è
questo quello che io volevo da piccolo
personaggi carismatici il bene contro il
male robot ancora adesso io riesco a
capire il perché ci sia piaciuto così
tanto quando eravamo piccoli e questa
puntata racchiude il senso di pausa
riuscire ad analizzare come una
mentalità matura quello che da piccoli
ci piaceva e non sapevamo perché vi
ringrazio ancora per aver seguito questo
episodio e ci vediamo di un prossimo
video